- I'm Mexican, we're the best at churros.
Do you have churros in Guatemala or no?
- I don't know, I think I've had...
I don't remember having
churros in Guatemala.
(cackles)
- I'm trying to lose
some weight right now.
I was kinda worried about
coming here right now.
- What I know about churros
is that I'm Mexican.
So I know churros, I think, a lot.
- I'm hoping it's a
tiny, churro-shaped Oreo
'cause anything else and quite frankly
I'm gonna be disappointed.
- No see I buy them from the
street vendors in my hood.
- I've decided that size
matters with churros.
- And those are the facts.
- Thanks man.
- I got you.
(microwave beeps)
You got yourself, I gotta get this.
Damn, these are smoking hot.
- Aw, they look so gross.
- The smell really good, what?
- I like this powder, I guess
it's like the powdered sugar.
- I don't know who you consulted, but that
granulated sugar is good.
- It's a nice touch.
- I burned myself.
- I'm too drunk to feel right now
so I'm pretty sure I just got burnt.
Ah, wait no I feel it!
- Ooh, okay this is firm.
- Oh-ho, yeah.
- It feels really firm and nice I like it.
- But it doesn't taste like anything.
It doesn't taste like Oreos
and it doesn't taste like churros.
- Not at all.
- Alright.
I get it.
- I mean this is definitely
a good drunk snack.
- So the cream doesn't have that
distinctive Oreo cream flavor.
It feels like cream.
- If I was at a store where
they sold these churros
I would probably get them
just in case I'm drunk.
Like right now.
It's like I get home and
I take a look at these
and I'm like how's it going guys?
- Would it be weird if
I dunk this in the milk?
- No it'd be sacrilegious if you didn't.
- I bet this will give you the runs.
And you don't want that, you don't, no.
- Churros, you only get
them from la senora.
You don't get them from anywhere else.
- Support your local street vendors.
- Support your local
street vendors, for real.
- As with anything
(speaks foreign language)
(laughs)
- You know what's good?
The little crumbs.
If I could just go like
that with the crumbs.
- No.
- Like this, like this.
That's good.
- I would personally recommend...
- He can't even say recommend.
- I know! I would eat all three of the...
I would eat all.
Yeah, there are three.